par vidéo conférence pour faire le point
sur les équilibres entre les grandes
puissances à l'épreuve de la pandémie
un entretien également sur les
principales crises à l'ordre du jour du
conseil de sécurité dont la syrie et la
libye le géant pharmaceutique sanofi
veut supprimer 1700 emplois en europe
dont un millier rien qu'en france un
plan sur la base du volontariat a étalé
sur trois ans selon la direction le
laboratoire affiche pourtant un chiffre
d'affaires en hausse au premier
trimestre avec près de 9 milliards
d'euros
une hausse liée notamment à la menthe
d'anti douleurs pendant la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
la crainte d'une nouvelle intifada en
israël alors que le gouvernement
israélien va décider dans les prochaines
heures de l'annexion pas d'un tiers de
la cisjordanie au 1er juillet sur le
terrain les avis restent très tranchées
entre palestiniens et colons israéliens
un projet d'annexion embarrassant pour
les pays arabes
un casse-tête pour l'union européenne à
paris le quai d'orsay s'est dit
déterminé à reconnaître un état
palestinien le moment venu fin de
citation
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi cet entretien
cet après-midi par écran interposé entre
vladimir poutine et emmanuel macron avec
de nombreux sujets à l'ordre du jour
entre les deux chefs d'état vous le
voyez les relations bilatérales entre
paris et moscou la situation en iran la
crise en syrie ou en ukraine avec le
dossier libyen qui est une priorité pour
l'elysée voyez les précisions de notre
correspondant à moscou
antoine clairon on a eu droit aux
premières minutes de l'entretien entre
vladimir poutine et emmanuel macron et
on pouvait sentir une certaine
convivialité et ce malgré le format en
visioconférence une convivialité
bien aidé par le tutoiement entre les
deux hommes deux jours après les
festivités du jour de la victoire
vladimir poutine a commencé par
souligner l'effort la contribution de la
france à l'issue victorieuse dans la
seconde guerre mondiale comme tu le sais
le 24 juin nous avons organisé le défilé
militaire en l'honneur de la fin de la
grande guerre patriotique comme nous
appelons cette stratégie donc cette
tragédie donc c'est en fait de notre
victoire commune est ici en russie
nous n'oublierons jamais les français
qui ont lutté à nos côtés sur le front
de l'est et même que des milliers de
citoyens soviétiques ont lutté dans les
rangs de la résistance française et tout
cela c'est notre héritage en commun
emmanuel macron a fixé plusieurs
objectifs pour cette relation
franco-russe dans un premier temps la
mise en place concrète de canaux de
discussion de canaux de communication
entre les deux pays
le lancer qui a fait seulement
maintenant c'est
de briançon puis à rappeler c'est à dire
la construction d'un agenda de confiance
et de sécurité entre
et je l'espère comme toi ta crise que
nous avons traversée comme tout écrit ce
gérant chez nous connaissons montre
l'importance de faire de l'espace
européen au sens large avance
je lis vos appels d'offres
[Musique]
une véritable espace de coopération et
de paix pour terminer emmanuel macron a
assuré à vladimir poutine sa volonté de
répondre positivement à son invitation
et donc de se rendre en russie d'ici la
fin de l'été
si la situation sanitaire le permet et
voyez les précisions à présent de bruno
de rêve ce qu'il est historien et maître
de conférences à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales les
chefs d'état cherche des points de de
stabilité dans un monde qui est de plus
en plus instable et bien sûr la russie
quoi qu'on pense macro emmanuel macron
et plus largement les dirigeants
occidentaux qui est quand même un bol de
stabilité et donc on peut supposer que
parler avec moscou c'est une façon de se
rattacher à quelque chose d'à peu près
très visible alors que de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique on se retrouve devant
une situation imprévue je pense que ce
qui a changé c'est le fait que d'abord
s'occuper les dirigeants des deux pays
se parlent régulièrement et qu'on est
définitivement semble-t-il quand même
sortis de la période de méfiance
systématique qui avait précédé au cours
des années précédentes
déjà sous la présidence du président
macro mais même avant et donc en ce sens
cela on peut dire que je sais pas si on
peut dire que la glace est rompue mais
tout au moins on se parle et on se parle
régulièrement et on on essaie de se
positionner par rapport à l'autre sur la
scène internationale le géant
pharmaceutique sanofi veut supprimer
1700 emplois en europe dont un millier
rien qu'en france un plan sur la base du
volontariat est étalé sur trois ans
selon la direction qui assure qu'il n'y
aura pas de fermeture de site
le laboratoire affiche pourtant un
chiffre d'affaires en hausse au premier
trimestre avec 9 milliards d'euros
une hausse liée notamment à la vente
d'anti douleurs pendant la crise
sanitaire
un plan jugé inacceptable et honteux par
les syndicats écoutez
c'est impensable pour nous on ne peut
pas comprendre on n'est pas d'accord et
on va combattre ces suppressions
d'emplois qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
elles servent à quoi c'est
catastrophique insupportable
inacceptable et honteux
on n'a plus de mots tellement on est
dans la rue structuration permanente
le groupe ne veut conserver que ceux qui
le plus rentable et se désengager des
médicaments les moins rentables
même si l'intérêt thérapeutique majeur
c'est la santé pour le fric et pour en
parler nous sommes avec pascal lopez
délégué syndical force ouvrière cadre
justement chez sanofi bonjour pascal
lopez merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france votre réaction tout d'abord à ce
plan social sanofi qui maintient son
plan d'économies malgré les bénéfices
un énième plan et profitant du sud en
pet entreprises locales d'ailleurs une
moyenne de 3 ans nous sortons déjà d'un
plan social qui a été vécu assez
difficilement par mes collègues on avait
supprimé récemment dans le cadre d'une
rupture conventionnelle collective dans
le département faire 1200 emplois 630
ici où je me trouve donc ils font des
fonctions supports du groupe et on nous
annonce la même chose cette fois-ci dans
mille suppressions d'emplois pour des
débats la base de départs volontaires
mais la problématique est relativement
simple c'est que les salariés sont bons
mais la charge de travail restent les
conditions de travail se dégradent et on
a les salariés qui ont font les crêpes
ce que nous avons vécu et très récemment
3 6 6 2 1 6 6 2 le 5 octobre à nous de 9
mai et un autre de 19 ans sahari chemist
donné la mort sur le site besantini
c'est plus important de talix que ce que
je comprends c'est que les cadences sont
de plus en plus soutenue alors que le
groupe licencie
il ya cent mille salariés
dans le monde 1 milite de deux postes
supprimés en france pourquoi la france
particulièrement selon vous je sais pas
si la france est considérée comme un
temps de coûts plus importants que les
autres pays
ce qui est certain c'est que
systématiquement la france fait partie
des pays qui payent un lourd tribut
moyens derrière des lunettes sous la
difficulté au tournant aujourd'hui c'est
que on n'a pas une vraie vision
on ne peut imaginer la vision
stratégique de l'entreprise
nous on a une idée assez c'est assez
simple et assez claire de ce que la
direction de serre mais cette direction
et toi ne veut pas communiquer sur le
sujet ou ne peut pas communiquer sur le
sujet ce nom banks est derrière ce
projet énième projet de réorganisation
des suppressions massives d'emplois il
ya autre chose
on vient de céder toutes nos parts dans
une société américaine s'appellerait
générons pas rapporter des chaussettes
17 milliards d'euros
cette entreprise est la septième est
tombé de la cinquième place à la 7ème
place au niveau mondial
je pense qu'elle n'a qu'un objectif de
reconquérir à septembre de place dans la
classification mondiale et le tribut à
payer pour arriver à cet objectif
c'est aussi de se servir comme nord à
variable d'ajustement
le personnel de l'entreprise on sait
qu'en soient les conséquences qu'on voit
bien non l'alerté les salariés à la
direction sur le sort des salariés
depuis maintenant des années un
l'alertent le droit d'aller à ce qu'on a
on vient de voter au niveau du canif et
laisser ce message est on arrivé à saint
ambroix dallaire pour danger imminent du
char la santé des salariés n'est que
l'aboutissement d'années il a l'air trop
speed on a demandé en octobre une
enquête sur le décès suspect tout à
l'heure en acide
on avait on avait un rapport si qui
accablaient
la responsabilité d'entreprise notamment
ce qu'on appelle l'évaluation de la
performance c'est le fait que les
salaires étaient insuffisamment
accompagnés à partir à chaque
réorganisation ajax projet sous
traitantes
on a énormément qui prêtait d'activité
dans cette entreprise
et puis dans des fringues a l'air
d'aller tous les métiers sont touchés
tous les métiers sont ici qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on remplace des salariés
en cdi il par les salariés et prétend
par des intérimaires par demain des
contrats de 100 sites que maintenant
c'était possible dans notre monde dont
franco et il est tout à fait la
précarisation des tarifs qu'à un moment
on retrouve totalement désespéré par
rapport à nous pour vous c'est c'est la
course au profit qui prime on sait que
ça nous fier a eu 7 % de hausse de son
chiffre d'affaires au premier trimestre
déjà en grande partie la moitié du grâce
au co vide
on a vu ces médicaments à l'image grasse
également les dividendes en plus son
sont bien plus conséquent que l'an
dernier ils ont été auditionnés la 9
milliards exactement 2 4 milliards de
dividendes le 9 milliards 9 milliards
pour le dessus d'affaires en
augmentation de 7%
le premier de ces bêtes dont
l'entreprise avec une marge
opérationnelle qui fait pâlir d'envié
beaucoup de l'entreprise quelle qu'elle
soit avec des projets de base
opérationnelle qui sont entre 25 et 30%
c'est ça aussi le projet qui est sur la
table c'est non seulement de réduire les
effectifs nous on veut augmenter encore
plus nos marges et ça te plaît forcément
d'être inondées et évidemment on se
souvient de cette polémique de la vente
de vaccins aux privilégiés pour les
états unis l'état français avait dû
intervenir pour vous clairement c'est
une course au profit
que fait heins sanofi de la première
pratique des vagues pas qu'il faut mais
à différents pronostics de ce tour de
financement
pas vraiment envie de rentrer sur le
sujet parce que je fais que l'état
l'état quand il a été sollicité n'a pas
les demandes de laboratoire pas plus que
l'europe d'où le fait que sanofi se soit
retourné dans les américains et que les
américains aient accepté le film est
contre le fait il voulait avoir la
priorité de la fourniture des vaccins
je compte alors les îles très court
alésia les i par contre par contre là où
nous on n'est plus d'accord et une
entreprise de réorganiser qu'elle était
de trouver un mode de fonctionnement
normal et la vie de l'entreprise
là où on n'est plus d'accord du tout
c'est que ça se fasse tant aux respecter
les fondamentaux d'une entreprise à
savoir le permettre à ses salariés
désolé correctement leur permettre de
pouvoir qui adapter leur emploi via la
formation ne pas te retrouver seule
patte un pack d'emplois
quand on réorganise ne pas se trouver
seul face à fabre problèmes notamment en
où l'évaluation de la performance que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure j'ai partie
des gens qui ont dénoncé un système de
rente si forte dans notre entreprise il
ya trois ans on a découvert qu'il y
avait des salariés qui étaient prêts
notez en début d'année donc évidemment
et avec une liste de 200 personnes qui
devaient être licenciés
tata n'a été fourni par mes collègues on
l'a démontée dans la radio et on n'y a
ni chat mais on voit bien qu'il ya un
processus d'entreprise à un système à
système si ce qui s'est passé si vite
voilà et qui se soucie assez que de la
santé des uns et des autres alors c'est
son métier c'est son coeur de métier non
c'est le coeur de métier les le tenant
de citer les tempêtes celles affrontées
moi je vais faire un mauvais du monde il
ya les copains c'est la santé des
salariés ou des actionnaires bon a
priori je pense que ce soit était fait
maintenant oui quand on quand on
privilégie des versements foncière de
dividendes à ses actionnaires
et qu'on le fait détriment de la santé
donc que l'on parle de la santé on parle
pas des salaires des conditions
pareilles ou de l'emploi n'en parle de
la santé selon il dit sanofi dit que
celle d'un plan social c'est une
nouvelle
tg on le sait quelques pans de la
recherche seraient sacrifiés notamment
sur le diabète est ce que c'est ça
véritablement seront peu on peut
l'appeler comme on peut derrière cette
expression emplois massives
moi je fais que dans mon activité
identité ça va être encore autour de 400
postes écrivent et faisant suite à 6
emplois supprimés précédemment et des
centaines y faire ça n'arrête plus voir
on enchaîne les plans sociaux le club
social précédent et descentes et arrêté
le 30 juin et on nous annonce
aujourd'hui un nouveau plan peut-elle
dire que le plan social ne s'est même
pas terminé on est déjà en train andrier
sur un second
merci l'as cannes voilà on merci pascal
lopez d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france les stocks des fameux
tests pcr qui ont fait tant défaut en
france pendant la crise seront ils
bientôt périmé et bien la réponse est
oui si une deuxième épidémie arriver à
l'automne
des millions de tests pcr ont été
commandés au plus fort de la crise
sanitaire par les laboratoires alors que
le rythme des nouvelles contaminations
lui a fortement baissé ces dernières
semaines et les donc les stocks
s'accumulent
retour sur cette gestion plutôt
chaotique de l'état en france
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
où
et voyez à présent l'analyse de lionel
baron il est président du syndicat des
jeunes biologistes l'état nous a demandé
de faire 700 mille tests par semaine
dans le privé uniquement donc les
laboratoires pour ça a été très
compliqué de s'organiser pour augmenter
nos capacités de test et finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on voit que on a beaucoup
moins besoin de tests que ce que l'on
croyait alors il ya une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que le virus
circule moins que ce que l'on pouvait
craindre donc ça il faut en fait il faut
s'en féliciter
et évidemment continuer les mesures
barrières et tout ce qu'on a mis en
place pour limiter la diffusion de ce
virus
par contre le souci c'est que du coup on
a fait des stocks pour 700 mille tests
dans le privé par semaine et on en fait
quatre fois moins donc on sait pas trop
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire de ces stocks
alors certains stocks vont jusqu'à
l'année prochaine
et là il n'y a pas de difficulté par
contre certains stocks seront périmées
dès septembre et il serait insupportable
et intolérable de devoir jeter des tests
vu la difficulté qu'on a eu pour les
obtenir et toujours concernant cette
crise sanitaire explosion des cas de
contamination en guyane des soignants
qui s'organisent pour tenter d'éviter la
suite la saturation du système
hospitalier
la guyane qui comptait hier plus de 3000
cas confirmés et d'idées c'est une
situation jugée préoccupante par santé
publique france françois xavier lambert
de gigantesque tente ont recouvert lancé
en héliport du centre hospitalier de
cayenne
voici l'hôpital de campagne fraîchement
installée pour accueillir les patients
non atteints par le coronavirus et
malgré l'apparenté rusticité des lieux
un matériel médical ultra sophistiqué il
ya été installée pour traiter les futurs
patients
un dispositif d'urgence déployée car
l'hôpital de la ville ne dispose pour
l'heure que de 16 lits de réanimation
adapté pour le coc vide 19
selon la ministre d outre mer ce renfort
est indispensable alors que le nombre de
personnes infectées double chaque
semaine dans le territoire
cet hôpital lui comporte quoi et bien
c'est 20 lits de médecine générale
c'est un bloc opératoire ces onze quand
ce sont aussi et c'est important et de
justice à qui permettront de mieux
sécuriser les approvisionnements
cet hôpital de campagne sera
opérationnel la logistique sera géré par
les équipes de l' élément de sécurité
civile rapide d'intervention médicale
l'escrim un personnel à la fois civile
et militaire
l'unité se concentrera notamment sur le
traitement de pathologies ne nécessitant
pas de longues prises en charge
nous assurons les patients combines pour
assurer ses passions dans provident
signalisation et pathologique typique
pourrait l'examiner xi l'exhortent le
plastique c'est l'accident
pendant la période la situation
épidémique en guyenne est suivie avec
préoccupation par le gouvernement
français la ministre d outre mer a
appelé les guyanais à respecter plus
strictement les gestes barrière et le
port du masque
de son côté la préfecture de guyane à
renforcer les mesures de restriction
pour lutter contre l'épidémie
fermeture des bars et restaurants sur
tout le territoire confinement ciblé
d'une vingtaine de nouveaux quartiers
fortement touchés et durcissement du
couvre-feu
la guyane devrait rester sous état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'à la fin
octobre
le pic de l'épidémie est lui attendu
pour la mi juillet
un moratoire sur l'utilisation de la
reconnaissance faciale pendant les
manifestations c'est l'appel de la haut
commissaire de l'onu aux droits de
l'homme le mouvement black l'animateur
qui demande lui aussi l'abandon de cette
pratique
plusieurs entreprises ont déjà suspendu
la vente de leurs logiciels aux forces
de l'ordre des technologies qui
pourraient aggraver les discriminations
selon ces entreprises réticentes à cet
usage
regardez la reconnaissance faciale ne
devrait pas être utilisé dans le cadre
de manifestations pacifiques sans la
mise en place de garanties essentielles
en matière de transparence de protection
des données et de surveillance et voyez
ce qu'en dit justement thierry valette
avocat au barreau de paris et
spécialiste en droits numériques
la haut commissaire de l'onu a tout à
fait raison je crois qu'aujourd'hui se
pose un problème fondamental presque
deux sociétés dans quel monde voulons
nous vivre
est ce que c'est un monde de
surveillance ou la reconnaissance
faciale permettra à tout un chacun
en tout cas d'être pisté par l'état des
troncs sera exactement où vous êtes à
n'importe quel moment par la
surveillance ou alors on veut le respect
de la des libertés fondamentales et
notamment celle de la vie privée la
vidéoprotection riant c'est devenu la
vidéoprotection pour des raisons
sécuritaires on est en train d'essayer
avec la technologie moderne de
d'utiliser la reconnaissance faciale
comme étant une ac mais pour permettre
de de piste et tout un chacun notamment
au niveau des manifestations dans la
foule donc il faut vraiment réfléchir à
tout cela et la cnil fort bien rappeler
ne serait ce biais encore quelques mois
il faut un véritable débat un véritable
débat société publique dans lequel on
serait exactement les tenants et
aboutissants entre les pro et toute
sécurité ou les pros liberté et vie
privée
au proche orient la crainte d'une
nouvelle intifada alors que le
gouvernement israélien doit décider dans
les prochaines heures de l'annexion pas
d'un tiers de la cisjordanie au 1er
juillet sur le terrain les avis restent
trancher entre palestiniens et colons
israéliens
un projet d'annexion plutôt embarrassant
pour les pays arabes
un casse-tête pour l'union européenne et
à paris le quai d'orsay s'est dit
déterminé à reconnaître un état
palestinien le moment venu fin de
citation
voyez les précisions denham medjahed les
décisions des israéliens sur une
extension de leur souveraineté sur ces
territoires sont des décisions qui
reviennent aux israéliens je crois que
le premier ministre israélien a fait
sien notre objectif c'est à dire que
notre vision pour la paix au
moyen-orient soit couronnée de succès
par ces mots washington donne de facto
son feu vert à israël pour l'annexion de
pans entiers de la cisjordanie occupée
les états unis veulent voir le plan de
donald trump pour le proche orient se
concrétiser les projets d'annexion
rencontre pourtant une opposition
grandissante à l'onu son secrétaire
général a d'ailleurs demandé ce mercredi
à israël de renoncer à ces plans qui
pourraient mettre fin aux efforts
internationaux en faveur de la création
d'un état palestinien viable
cette annexion si elle était mise en
oeuvre constituerait une violation des
plus graves du droit international
neyret sévèrement à la perspective d'une
solution à deux états et amoindrirait
les possibilités d'une reprise des
négociations si les palestiniens sentent
qu'il n'y a pas de perspective pour une
résolution pacifique du conflit
cela ne fera que créer des opportunités
pour des radicaux des personnes avec des
intentions dévastatrice pour venir
remplir ce vide des mises en garde
lancées sans pour autant parler de
sanction lors d'une visioconférence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu toute
dernière rencontre internationale avant
la possible mise en oeuvre dès le 1er
juillet de ses plans d'annexion
pour le chef de la diplomatie
palestinienne riyad al malki tout
annexion de territoires palestiniens par
israël serait un crime
quant à la diplomatie israélienne avait
réagi par la voix de son ambassadeur à
l'onu devant le conseil
il a reproché aux palestiniens d'avoir
refusé de venir négocier avec son pays
rejetée en bloc par les palestiniens le
projet de l'administration américaine a
aussi été dénoncée par l'union
européenne et la ligue arabe annexé des
parties du territoires palestiniens
occupés constituerait si cela se
concrétise une menace sérieuse à la
stabilité régionale ce plan détruirait
toute idée de paix à l'avenir dans ce
climat de crainte à la proche du 1er
juillet le mouvement armé palestinien le
hamas a lui haussé le ton la résistance
considère cette décision d'annexion de
la cisjordanie et de la vallée du
jourdain comme une déclaration de guerre
contre notre peuple palestinien la
résistance dans cette guerre sera un
gardien fidèles de ce peuple et de ses
lieux saints dans le détail ce plan pour
le proche-orient des états unis prévoit
l'annexion par israël de la vallée du
jourdain et de la centaine de colonies
en cisjordanie où sont installés 450
mille israéliens les colonies pourtant
illégales au regard du droit
international
s'ajoute à cela la création d'un état
palestinien sur un territoire réduit est
mort seul et sans jérusalem est pour
capitale
les palestiniens réclament des sanctions
et envisage désormais de saisir la cour
internationale de justice et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité sur notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec moi
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas de ces mini psy d'aujourd'hui en
france les causes et les violences il
existait avant le confinement et pendant
ce confinement c'est vrai qu'il ya sept
ce cadre les captures les taux des
féminicides a plus que je dis pas doublé
mais bien monté forcément on n'a pas
encore tous les chiffres précis